you
Jerry I'm on leeches org and I'm going
to play a 15-10 game okay mitah c'n
youtube is the opponent alrighty let's
start with e6
hmm
well I'm gonna go with this BOGO Indian
all right now it is
point a 5 or a capture is also Queenie 7
I'm going to play with something like
this so okay I'm one day looking forward
to maybe clamping down on this structure
now so kind of wanted to induce this
move I have to be a bit careful about
maybe playing this too early here really
Knight c3 Queen c2 kind of gang up on
that pawn so
think something more in the future
think I might want to take into account
my knight on f6 it's post so I'm
thinking about d6 here and e5 the timing
has to be right by Castle Knight c3 d 6e
4 I'm not in time to play e5 and I might
have to face 'if I've by white so that
said
let's begin putting some pawns on dark
squares to make this guy happy already
oh you know what here's another thing I
think there's a variation yeah
queenie 74 if i do this
takes takes queen g5
hitting g7 in my pond
that could get a little nutty okay well
there's not too much I could do about
that
I've had this I think I've had this
position before not in a standard game
oh ok so White's going much more
conservative all right well I kind of
had an idea to just give up this pawn
and play for some activity there if
white goes in for that here here I guess
we could have a look at it afterwards if
I remember okay
that's not happening white is just
working with a C for D for structure
what am i considering castles castles e5
hmm
yeah castles re5 I'm just trying to see
if what if there's a a great difference
if I do this I'm giving up this square
do I really care about them
I get in I'm not going to be castling
queenside
no no I'm gonna just go with castles not
quite I can't really figure out a
difference between the two okay I guess
actually maybe if I play the e5
this would stop Bishop d3 because I
could capture and white isn't able to
recapture because of the pin but okay
after I castles the the bishop ends up
not even going to d3 so that that's
maybe a difference at least and I think
we're now ready for g5 yeah once let's
go with the e5 er I could go with this
no let's go with you five know what I
would love to see happen yeah I was
gonna say I'd love to see this push
because of then this and then circle the
night in to c5 I did this in the last
standard game I played alright so Queen
c2 is a very good move
is preparing to meet for with 92 opens
up d2 and it also prevents this a4 idea
purpose very good
[Music]
at 3:00 - huh okay I'm thinking about
Bishop
for and yeah am i okay with deploying
the bishop already hmm they have to be a
little bit careful here here no I think
I'll be all right with that
I'll be okay with playing g6 to cover
the f5 square there's no dark square
bishop around
how to get my bishop playing
see 6 is another move
consider c6 with this idea I don't like
because I give up a big square on b5 so
basically if I play a5 trying to go
forward with efore and then securing it
with d5 is kind of not a good idea
now that square is too strong okay so
I'm not going to play c6 let's let's get
the bishop out
okay you know just double-checking
thing there might be something fancy
here in the night jumping in alright
you
No
is this maybe a little bit of a
different story now e4
hmm if I play E 492 Bishop takes Knight
takes could I get in this a four move
hmm I do this and the the night moves
after takes I will be distracting one of
these pieces from observing a four
here 92 I expect here takes a four and
if the night returns
the night returns I still have to watch
over this Queeny Queeny e8 still
watching e4 and defending this pawn I
don't know how I have a really complete
development in that position does not
feel natural maybe I could prepare it
rook here first still keep this tension
and then and then think about e4 next
hmm or even a capture
you
I'm gonna hold my ground um I wanna play
yeah let's play rook e8 I could play b4
right now like I kind of want to see d5
so I could maybe get in this Square the
tension remains between these guys I
could have also considered a flight
square retaining flexibility with the
Queen Knight not sure where it wants to
go just yet
so I guess this is the first moment
where white is really thinking
if my bishop has asked a question I
think I just dropped back to h5
this is going to be a queenside game
something's going to happen here I mean
takes takes night here I think I have to
take and then I'm thinking I have to
play c6 and challenge that strong pawn
immediately
takes you know I'm just recapturing and
developing could have a little bit of a
weird queenside structure that we
weaknesses but um I don't see too much
action going on on the kingside I mean
if I if I push with e4 that's kind of
hinting that I want to maybe go after
the king but I don't think I'm really in
a position to do that
okay so b4 on board
yeah I wonder if this is maybe a time to
take and open up the center takes hmm
justify the rook
of
I don't know that I want to take
this beep on is going to be
a bother takes takes nine c6 b five
where am i going from there
this guy is struggling
hmm
I think I should keep this tension for
one
I could still think about c6
you
you
it's tricky to be sure if I take here
Knight takes
I'll have a square for my night I like
that
if I take in pond takes
bothers me I think my queen will have to
move soon and mmm not liking my position
so far
well
you
I'm actually considering night here and
then they push me back they've done that
push me back I'll be okay with trying to
reroute
hmm
I don't like 97 because of night b5
although although maybe that's alright
97 95 maybe maybe I could try that I got
to get a move in oh boy it's not going
so well
yeah stay out of my pawns way
to be careful I mean I I keep thinking
that there might be something with night
h7 my bishop is somehow unprotected and
okay let's see how exactly that's
happening but it's a thought at least
here pulling a key defender away but I
should be alright with the Knights
connected it always replenished this guy
you
hmm if it was my move here what should I
do sneak in a flight square something
fast
probably could have played this a little
bit faster I was kind of I don't know I
just thought that night b5 would have
been uncomfortable but I could I could
just move my night
yeah I think it makes sense rook e8 and
then this because it's timely right
Knight d5 Knight f8 and just in time
get out of the Queen's way okay III
think I think this is okay this is this
is kind of harmonious
expecting hear from ye b5 put the rook
on a ask where asked my bishop a
question takes I wouldn't mind c5 is
getting really sharp c5 maybe then I
could go for something like this
I don't know it still give up that be
five square
you
I could get in c6 though it'd be a
different story
you
you know c5
or 90 oops c5e 492 Bishop takes Knight
takes and then I could help with d5 in
the be five square that I was concerned
about earlier isn't isn't an issue
now White has to be a bit careful let's
say of about the c-4 square so depending
on how the pawns advance on the Queen
side if I'm able to establish a pond
here and the light square Bishop SAR
exchanged I'm not long off from having a
giant pest in White's camp a knight on
c4 killer so right now he's just a
second rank Knight but he could become a
beast
so working with lights
Bishop's pawns in the center are on dark
tension remains white is better here
I believe better place two nights mmm
more space that's the biggest thing to
me
on the queenside now I don't see I don't
know if my queen is really gonna be
vulnerable the White Queen could be
vulnerable depending on what happens
with these guys there may be a valuable
tempo I could gain against the Queen
and it's tricky when you have this kind
of a fluid structure there's really a
lot to consider you know there's a lot
of different ideas why could go with
just shut things down
maybe with B 5 C 5
d5 I don't think is a good idea I think
white does well to maybe get a rook
involved maybe this is an idea even
threatening to take and then take on b7
but I think on rugby when I get played
b6 pretty sure the computer will be
saying white is better here
h4 is an idea
on night h4 I don't here's here's one
thing if nine h4 and I take White has an
in-between move with Knight f5 to
recapture on e - so if night h4 I could
maybe just play this straight away but
my bishop may wrote and be very short on
school here's roof night h4 g6 maybe
this is what white is calculating
Knight h4 g6 can be met with f3
the night on each floor is unprotected
but I don't really have a good Square to
move my knight to to attack the h4
square I teach for g6 f3 if I go Knight
h5 this pawn takes my bishop and then is
on my knight after Queen takes Knight
okay scratch all that okay I'm assuming
white is really gearing up for c5
advance to justify the rook position it
is closed in the way that it would open
up is with c5 I think that's a good move
yep
flight square time and if so which
flight square maybe maybe this actually
have an option for fur
oh here's the other thing not this move
but also night here yeah that's what's
being lined up night here takes takes
and then if I do this that's I don't
have enough defense of that okay do I
have to place c6 right now
I wonder
this too many holes
here takes takes oh no that's
structure white would have a connected
passer and this pond would be half dead
scratch that felt bad it is bad I don't
know what do I want to do efore here
light square bishop exchange
I won't hurt no no I was I want to take
and take I push h6
don't have a clear plan c6 maybe stop
what it is white wants to do
I'm going to look to play against the
night
yeah this might be a more of a practical
decision than objectively best
fear with what it is white is clearly
lining up as otherwise you know
WAIS maybe just going to follow right
through and pull off another fast move
we both eat we have both eaten a lot of
our clocks and this is related to not
having a defined structure I think so c5
hmm I think I'm ready to play d5
on d5 I'll reconsider the move c5 in
this case because white won't be able to
capture in a way where this this pawn
becomes connected and passed
protected past pond
mooove I've weakened some dark squares
can they be taken advantage of I'm not
seeing how that can happen
okay now things are definitely changing
and I think to my benefit with that
capture let's pull this move off pretty
quick why do I like this position for me
now exerting pressure here maybe white
is gonna go in for this maneuver to be
very careful I was just pointing out the
dark squares I'm threatening to maybe
win upon you know the B pond would fall
but okay at least I'm exerting pressure
here okay so now
now how can we maybe do something good
white has an idea to just drop in here
that's going to be a giant pain do I
take now and create some tension between
the rooks
you
another thing is maybe do it
my bishop for the night
just so I don't have to worry about this
hmm
um triki triki triki I'm gonna give this
imbalance ago and maybe get this rook
somewhere else really recaptured
considering capturing with the pawn
that'd be surprising oh maybe they're
considering a if they take with the
bishop I do this
I guess I could consider that
I was thinking just get on an open file
and fight against even a rook arriving
on d6 that could be irritating
Bishop takes e4 Bishop e2 I can't get
this move in because I'm blocking my
major pieces my e4 pawn would fall
I still want to keep this tension this
isn't a movie
nor is this I want to kind of keep like
guessing
when will I open up the a file white is
really considering the capture with the
pawn Wow
isn't a knight on h4 gonna be brutal I
would love to see pawn takes this night
is gonna quickly arrive on h4 that's
that's something I could shoot for do it
do it you know you want to take with the
pawn and there isn't something else I'm
missing here now there isn't a
connection thing white must really be
considering upon context I mean I mean I
don't know I am giving white a file to
work with possibly
but I think it becomes more of a minor
piece bad I don't think I'd have to fear
too much along the the G file I can
always get one rook off real quick - or
even have my knight sit here blocking
this kind of a threat
okay Allen let me consider just this I
have an idea at least with the pun oh
wow okay I guess they were really
fearing e4 let's go straight in for
so we got two tricky nights and a clean
on and now some holes to work with there
are three holes now because of this last
capture one two three in this section so
the one that will be very annoying to
white is a night on each floor now these
two nights are combating for the light
squares in the center and
they're exchanged I kind of like that my
Queens eyes are opened up along this
diagonal now if possible I'd like to try
and keep the Queens on the board because
I have the safer King
better shell
I mean if Bishop here and then this I'm
okay I even I still have a better
shelter white doesn't have a Jeep on so
even in some instances where let's say
maybe down upon if as long as the
Queen's are still on possibilities for
perpetual checks are nearby for me okay
well I don't want to see this I let's
let's just take the night out
Queens gonna take up a nice post mm-hmm
so here
that coin is going to be strong maybe is
now the time to make this captures
otherwise this move hmm 96 are a capture
or chuck now check is just ducks and to
worry about that hmm oh well okay hang
on for a second
maybe I should shift ears some with my
night maybe this is the most efficient
square to challenge the Queen because
how else while I challenge the Queen I
don't want to do this I want a week in
my light squares I'm gonna opt for this
and I think this is a good decision
because it also interferes with this
idea I could grab this pawn so my
primary aim is to find a better square
for my knight and challenge this Queen
so knight on f6 I'm I'm
up on this idea to put a knight on each
for I want the night to rest right here
I'll have some nice follow up moves at
some stage g6 King g7 slow study and
proven improvements okay I think I need
to get here right now
why can't run in for this too soon
because of this tension the rook would
be unprotected as soon as the rook moves
okay
I could get another tempo against the
Queen
I'm going to sneak this in I have
covered rook d6 I take any any rook
lifts this is the most invasive but I'll
be protecting it Queen here I'll step up
so that rook d6 isn't hitting with tempo
I'll have two pieces on it this is where
my king wants to be anyhow I think I'm
the better side here
I think he'd slow least
earn my way after white initiated the
capture and is probably the case white
is now feeling as comfortable with the
position anymore with the time edge that
white did have but it still remains
tense
where else is the
I'm gonna go I don't want to see this
what kind of productive role will this
Bishop play here here's the only thing
okay
this
make one capture think I'm going to
break the attention now
do I want to put my Kenyan g7
tough to say I'm just
back rank then it's it's debatable you
know there could be some problems on
this diagonal but could be a problem
here at some stage Bishop taking with
check I don't know tough to say okay
maybe my each pawn this isn't something
this isn't a weakness that I can take
advantage of that's a weird move I'm not
sure what its point is
I thought b5 and with the Queen on see
to that b5 would be a good idea kind of
breakdown
structure a little bit more but okay
here we are
maybe maybe I could race this pawn all
the way up to age three and look for
some some maid on g2 I think I'd like to
not only keep the Queens on but also one
rook
keeps wide a little bit honest if this
truck tries to get it a little excited
I'd have to worry about the back rank
this shelter this is what I keep coming
back to the the king shelter
this one's cozy know how far
I think going one more step is
purposeful second one to h3 it could
drop off if I'm not careful but one step
I think I'm cool with okay or even even
maybe a push and then this and then that
now there's h3 okay a rook left even no
you know what maybe even both rocks off
is okay hmm
no I think I'm going to stick with uh
trying to keep one broke on I go with h4
this is maybe a thing now that the
defended with the Queen so that's maybe
the idea maybe it's time to get this
rook doing something
yeah let's get the rook on an open file
we're both on the only two open files
and yeah remains tense
know about we do have 10 second
increment all right let's go with this
rook yeah rook here I
have this guarding my base points I like
the rook here there's some nice harmony
between my knight and rook
maybe my queen could kind of look to do
something besides sit on this e7 square
listen she only made one move right okay
wait a second though that's giving up
this square in some cases if the Queen
goes too far so I get in this move now
sneak that in I'll make white star
thinking about you know am I going to
take away the flight square and then
look for back-back ranked tricks so
square but if I need to I have this to
defend Knight defends rook King defends
night my queen gets a little bit too
aggressive this can fall okay it's
probably a good decision
what white did there suppose I go here
you
pressure on the pond
here here takes oh no no no no no maybe
you're getting to this square how do I
get my knight where's there a good
square for my knight
oh maybe this oh I think I like that
idea
my knight is killed by this pawn Knight
h7 into here and then maybe Queen here
and this collapses ooh that might be
something
that night on g5 queen on f6 as well
yeah I want to try and put pressure on
these two two pawns they're both
unprotected so Knight g5 is really going
to put some constraint on white soon
this kind of stuff
this I don't know that it's really would
be working here's the other thing a
night on g5 helps assist defending f7
multi-purpose if this to stop my g5 i
could always take double isolated pawns
maybe return and do something along this
file yeah that'd be way to weakening I
think I found a good idea I'm not
missing anything tactically I have my
base points like my queen is doing a
good job defending my pawns there's a
check available to keep an eye on the
check two checks available to legal
checks not not a good move at the moment
rook d1 my pony is under a minute
okay and if I jump in right now what's
the plan I think I'm winning no let's
let's do this for starters also let's be
aware of this dog and all in case
something opens up their queen is kind
of off sides so if Bishop here Queen
here how is white defending Queen takes
pawn bishop here I take here with check
why may need to do this but then my
knight is going on a rampage well that's
okay here we go so I could take
and then play queen here I have to worry
about checks myself
take first hmm takes takes night here up
here takes takes here hmm I think I
first let's let's take yeah
is this is getting tricky mm-hmm okay
could play f6
it's an interesting in your media move
clean up six takes takes takes who here
takes takes takes Knight here the bishop
has to take
I still think I want to keep the the
Queen's on the board
let's try
this pin the pond
you
Wow tough here and then here gotta go
fast
anything can happen oh okay
in this move
this clean exchange can have
have a square for my name okay I got a I
got a take so if this and
this and this pawn helps out I think
that this is good for me okay
my knight isn't he a tricky guy okay
nice square why could try an
intermediate move with this but I do
have a nice square okay this
I think I want to go here he
and stuff I might have been a bad move I
think this is a good move now yeah that
ponds fast I do have a square now though
I think that was a mistake
giving up this nice square my king was
shouldered off
I was thinking rook here's available
that's now the case I do have a check
this bishop goes too far away so now if
this I could take and then win this pawn
bishop is restricted
why does a white is really tied up okay
so I could go for this now saying
anything
take whoa keep pressure on that bishop
though right
anywhere here here I win the bishop
check
maybe I should have pushed this pawn
it's past we both have passers I have a
check Oh
check here and then here the King has to
go back save this pawn
my rook had at some point give a fork or
something to the bishop where where's
the bishop safe Square mm-hmm reposition
the knight now I think now let's go with
this I don't want to give this square up
too too soon I'm going to go with
to go back otherwise I get the put
pressure on the bishop
push pressure on the [ __ ]
where's the bishop go here where does
the bishop go
I think the rook has to go here I could
go here
for a poem these two restrict these
three
what am i doing if rook here I think
that's the best move
just rook c3 if I exchange the rooks I
win let's keep that in mind I think
let's try this pressure on multiple
points going this pawn who won hang on
to this let's try here
up too easily here I could take no yeah
I could hear takes that move I have of a
block
okay let's try this we're both living
off of the increment rook takes I'll be
the night
sacré watch offers
fancy like I want to hunt this pawn down
okay let's see how what's wrong with
this because I have this covered that
Mel take and then move my
to a good square let's see let's go here
rook here check here check or just no
simpler is this and then have my King
defend now my king will be here I have
everything glued together yeah this is
cleanest Bishop's out of play now yeah
bishops not playing
as the bishop play I got these covered
only has this square now poni resigned
poof what a tough game felt like I was
playing off the increment the whole game
Wow very very tough resistance that
middle game position Wow
let's see before I go through the
analysis
yeah I think I think things changed once
white captured on e5 hmm yeah III
gonna be an evaluation change here we'll
see what the computer suggests for white
maybe ask the bishop a question maybe c5
trying to justify the rook move make the
C file open up
endgame yeah that was a very interesting
I don't know that was a big decision I
don't think the computer would be going
with that just the bishop takes and if
efore back up and although maybe maybe
with Bishop takes e4 maybe maybe I could
kind of circle around like this and it
could be tricky
yeah pawn on pawn on e4 Knight on h4
Queen on g5 do I have time to get that
stuff in I don't know huh made for an
interesting game to be sure having this
different structure I like that I came
up with that idea to put the knight on
f6 but my opponent defended well f4 was
maybe a best move in the in-betweener
you know once we got here I think I
think I'm better in the endgame
the Queen's off I think I'm better maybe
something else
this might be this might be something no
it could be lost here's the thing this
white is not playing with their King in
this end game okay let's let's just jump
into the analysis yeah I think somebody
already clicked on it you know check
back in a little bit so these arrows off
so I'm kind of just sipping through with
one eye on the evaluation looking for
any great jumps
to share a lot and during this game
Knight B to d7 now I want to put my pawn
on e5 um
B to d7 and then b6
this is what computer wants me to do
something like this what am i doing on
that move okay I have to be mr. timely
94 than this okay
um I don't like I don't like playing b6
I want to keep up in the option for this
kind of a structure like I eventually
did in the game it's it's more fluid
like I have potential for this I play b6
I'm never really and I feel like I'm
maybe subjecting myself one day to
having that structure clamped down on
with the pawn on b5 just like I was
talking earlier about clamping down on a
for this structure or not climbing down
a name for clamping down on this
structure with a for if I'm playing b6
just to kind of make dummy moves
something like
b5 here I just I didn't like this kind
of possibility static structure beep on
clamping down on b6 and c7 I know
there's a lot of moves played but it's
it's kind of my train of thought steer
clear of b6 I miss anything here wants
to go with a okay Bishop g4 Knight B to
d7 I think I spent a little bit too much
time on that yeah like a minute and a
half on Knight B to d7
I know rook rook to e8 I played first
and b4 and I'm better here really why
I'm better by initiating a capture this
is where I spent a yeah like two minutes
with night here but apparently I could
take exchange rooks and then I probably
have a timely knight c6 move here here a
whole that is pretty slick why would get
back rank mated if a recapture on e4
okay
that wasn't I didn't I didn't consider
all those exchanges whoo well they
certainly are forcing I did not see that
coming though to kind of give up the
bishop for the night like that but yeah
there's a clear point with a back ranked
mate okay and I could once more going
for this capture what am I
maybe not assessing properly with this
sequence Bishop Te'o this same okay it's
the same tactic yeah nothing really
changed rook on now forgotten see in the
end it's recapturing on anyone okay so
that's that same tactic trying to take
advantage of the back rank so once you
go with the b5 here you know I think it
makes sense to still hold this tension
and changes a little bit with
caPSURE now rook a seven oh this one
didn't cross my mind to try and double
up and then threaten to take and do
something on the a file okay this is
where I initiated the exchange
what's the I'm not getting anything here
oh there it is
mmm okay this is where we stay
accuracies mistakes blunders for each
side plenty for each doesn't like my
decision to take the night and after G
takes I guess I'm better it's even and
then I have an advantage and then it's
nothing at some point but yeah big
decision here white went with the very
interesting G takes so if this what
would I be doing
efore here and then
night around so maybe H for one of the
ideas
Knight is ever kicked it could jump into
a nice square kind of connects really
well with this pawn Knight on h4 on on
e4 coordinate on f3
hmm yeah I don't know it's tough to
assess
structure went with the pawn Knight
takes does it like 97 h6 does like 97
I'm glad I found that move I was very
tempted to try for something like this
but the queen is just so strong an e4 if
I'm going to do anything I have to I
have to make sure this Queens post is
challenged it's way too strong so I'm
able to gain a tempo against the Queen
what else where is it changing still
still even ish one rock off you nuts now
it's a bit scary for white I'm gonna
deal with this pawn and queen and night
are still around the rook as well Knight
h7 I'm happy to have spotted that move
Queen f6 Oh Queen f6 that way I don't
have to worry about this F and F 4 move
Queen f6 to put pressure here
oh yeah and now
for his whites fighting back so if I
played this first I was too much of a
rush to play that move hmm no Queen f6
is nice and on Bishop e2 then Knight g5
there isn't this Knight isn't getting
flushed away and now there's even this
idea converging on h3 Queen c4 Oh I'm
also on f3 with this last move yeah so
if King here I'm just winning on h3 ah
Queen f6 instead of Knight g5 okay I
capture
f6 okay I guess both f6 and King h7 is a
move okay
and in Queens
all right rook d4 is another Oh Oh
what's this about wait a second oh wow
this is a wild tactic rook d4 and if the
knight is captured I win the Queen Queen
e5 check in no matter where the king
goes I have a rook move with the
discovered check the queen is lost okay
I don't think I was in any position on
the clock neither of us were neither of
us were in any position on the clock to
find something fancy like that rook d4
yeah okay okay I went with Queen c7 rook
d4 once more also yeah that's the other
thing a fork my knight is there
defending d4 indirectly Knight f3 is
equal rook d4 is minus 3 yeah this this
is winning flat out Bishop and pawn ok I
went into defensive mode and they'll
keep suggesting Rick d4 the Queen
change I guess this is the last
different or change in the evaluation
after f5 f32 key
night out hmm yeah I would have
struggled my night would have had a very
difficult time finding a good square
even if he gets to f6 he's under
controlled by this pawn but once he's
here he's annoying and if he's kicked
he's still annoying gets to g3 so white
went with a queen exchange and I think
it's I think it's a lot easier for me to
play here because my King is playing and
White's isn't just goes downhill from
there who tough game
very tough game so anything more to add
other things so you know I'm just push
this is the last idea just have that
pawn defendant I think I could have also
gone in for this and then this and then
that a little bit fearful of that move
because my knight is kind of stranded
but I guess I'll be there in time but I
just kind of saw if I get my king to c5
and this guy's defended these pieces
aren't none of the white pieces are
playing this endgame so this is where
white resigned Wow
very tense game to be sure anyhow as
usual feel free to leave any feedback to
this one in the comment section below
hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two why that's all for now take
care bye
you